he's the hall of famer turner sports
play-by-play announcer marv albert
called last night's wizards celtics
play-in tournament
alongside grant hill you can follow the
eastern conference playing tournament
finale tnt will air
more nba playoff games than any other
network
starting this sunday may 23rd always
great to hear marv albert's voice who
joins us now
marv announcing his retirement following
this year's postseason
mark thanks for joining us why now
always a pleasure why am i joining you
now no why are you retiring
i'm kidding uh i just felt 55 years
of nba and year 60 in broadcasting
overall
it's it's enough and uh my two pugs
trixie and madison
insisted that i spend more time with
them my wife heather
kind of on the fence in that area
but uh i i i think i will miss
a lot of things about broadcasting uh
particularly the nba
it's more uh the preparation and you
know the people that you deal with and
uh and the people in the nba
particularly the coaches who you get to
know
uh so well uh over the years and many
who i've worked with
when they turn to broadcasting but uh
i won't feel it then i think until next
november when the season
starts because i'd normally have the
summer anyway so
uh as i said i just i just think
it was time i don't want to be one of
those uh people that you know just keeps
going and going
i probably could have gone a few more
years but i thought this was the right
time
i was wondering that you were calling
rangers games calling knicks games so it
was territorial there
um and and then when you start to do
national broadcast i didn't know
if any network executive tried to change
you
and your style or voice to have it
conform to i guess what we think should
be a national broadcaster
instead of a local one yeah you know
that
i think that's changed now when you you
know you listen
be it uh the networks uh
over the air or cable people who are
doing games
you have different styles now i think
that's really changed
to the type of voice or the type of
style
uh where everything was kind of straight
too straight laced in terms of
the presentation uh no no one ever tried
uh i must say but that may have
something to do with the fact that
uh the networks were all stationed
primarily in the new york area and they
heard me there
okay so it was acceptable
there and there was a degree of success
there so i
they i never had anybody say anything
like that no
greatest performance you ever witnessed
on the basketball floor
in a game you called
there were a number of them i i can tell
you
in terms of uh an event
the 92 dream team uh which i was
fortunate
to broadcast for nbc that was the
i got the chills when they first came
out in the tournament of america's i
remember that
they had a qualify in portland oregon
and you see the greatest team ever
assembled in sports history you know why
they all weren't walked out
on the court and got the standing
ovation michael and magic and stockton
and barkley and bird and so on
malone um that wasn't just an incredible
moment in terms of major games
several of them involved michael jordan
the the flu game
the six threes against portland when he
wasn't really a three-point shooter but
i recall he came out early
way before the guys came out to warm up
just to shoot threes
and then he hit the sixth and i was
working with the czar
mike fratello uh you recall that name
and also magic johnson and then michael
had that shrug when he hit the sixth
looking over towards our table
he was actually looking at michael
although mike portello claims he was
you know giving him a sign and looking
at him which wasn't
wasn't the case but uh that was
one of the great thrills there were
also situations in my days uh with the
knicks
when they won their first championship
in 6970 there were
several dramatic games when willis reed
got heard
people thought he was not going to play
in game seven
uh and then he walked out out of the
court
late in warm-ups and i recall the laker
team just stopped
and stared will chamberlain couldn't
believe that uh
willis was taking the court and he hit
two jump shots early
yeah and i was i mean that basically
that was his contribution except for the
fact that he inspired them
and it was really uh you know as one of
the great moments in new york
sports when they won because they had
they'd never won a championship then
they won in 73 it wasn't quite
the same feeling they won in la so you
didn't have the new york
fans on hand but uh that was a uh
just a terrific team because of the
style they played with uh you know the
ball movement
uh it's kind of like phil jackson's
triangle in later years
and uh it was such a smart team you know
bill bradley and
uh phil was on that team although he was
injured that year and
uh dave the busher willis clyde
people forgotten game seven because all
the uh
conversation dealt around willis playing
but walt frazier had one of the
all-time greatest playoff games he had
36
points 19 assists seven rebounds
and uh that sometimes is forgotten
except when clyde
mentions it on the air
well he was also going against jerry
west i think he also had six steals in
there
it was andy and he didn't win mvp willis
willis got mvp right he did
yes he had some good games
good games early but he got hurt
actually in game five and
that was red holes who was the head
coach
accepted input from his players
particularly bradley and the busher
and there were no other you know there
were no assistant coaches in those days
but uh bradley and the bushes suggested
a movement offense that really worked
against uh a a laker team that was you
know was chamberlain
west uh it was
uh it was they were a super team
although they only you know jerry west
just won the one championship as it
turned out as great as he was
but uh it was really the
the busher and bradley's input uh
so i i think that had a lot to do with
it because
now you see benches where you know there
are ten coaches you know five sitting
behind
uh the regular bench and it's it's a
completely different situation and
you know it's advanced so uh
uh dramatically in recent years in terms
of what the coaches do and the video
work and the analytics
it's so different than the basics that
red holes motor red hour back
had and of course both had great success
what's the strangest thing you ever
witnessed on the basketball floor
well this was on the floor and off the
floor
that would be the finals game
1994 there was
nix houston and uh it was june
17th i believe and i'm doing the game
uh courtside and all of a sudden
people are looking at the monitors which
were at the press table and it was the
day
of the o.j chase and i'm going back and
forth
with the basketball play-by-play and tom
brokaw back in the nbc studio
and the players are wondering what's
going on
uh in fact uh
pat riley asked what's happening and
uh kenny smith who was then with the
rockets
was right at the uh nick bench it was it
was
uh during a lull in the action and
riley asked him what's going on he said
kenny says to pat
that chasing o.j simpson uh which is not
giving you much information
no but this this went on right
throughout
people uh who were near courtside
when the press was at courtside and they
had also tv monitors
just hunched over all the newspaper men
and watching the chase as this game is
going on
in the finals i would say that's that
was the most bizarre i've been
uh ever been part of the other
uh crazy moments i had when i was doing
the olympics
uh for nbc in 88 in seoul
the shamshill students gymnasium where
the boxing was held
and it was such a crazy setup and it
came out later as we suspected
there were so many fights being fixed
and you know there's all kinds of stuff
going on
but they had two rings going
at the same time so you had bouts in one
one ring and in another area you had
bouts going on
and the you know the bell that ends
rounds
uh from the ring say
at the far side would be heard at the
near side
and boxers would stop and a couple of
times guys when knocked out
because they stopped fighting off the
bell
they thought the round was over you know
and that was that was
also the uh series of fights where roy
jones was
robbed oh yeah a decision
and uh there's another uh
were you on the call marv when the the
was it the bruins and rangers and
is this when you had the fight in the
stands
were you on the call with that one you
know no i wasn't
i was doing a nick game out of town
oh okay but i that was that was the
situation where the bruins
actually went up into the stands which
was to the right of our broadcast booth
which was very low then at the uh
at the garden it was over uh what they
call the vomitory where the players came
out
so i i missed that one was mike miller
involved
was beating somebody with a shoe yes
uh yeah i i i saw
far too many fights uh when i was doing
hockey but
i i try to use my uh boxing uh
play-by-play
skills at the time but uh i mean
i thought they had a pretty good handle
on it
uh in terms of of cutting down on it
because it's ridiculous i mean
uh but i think there was the feeling
that
this is part of what is attractive to um
a segment of of fans and then we saw the
tom wilson
situation a couple weeks ago against the
rangers and
it was terrible you know so you know i
was just
wondering this this time you know next
year in the fall
this sounds like something letterman
would have done as a skit he would have
you down at the park
calling little kids playing basketball
play-by-play because
you're you're retiring right yeah
that sounds like something letterman was
doing well we had a similar skit once
where i'm calling the game it's funny
you mention this because
uh it was i was sitting
on a couch in his office he had a
basketball game on
and he asked me this was a skit to come
in and call the game
so uh so letterman has you on his couch
and you're
watching a basketball game yeah yeah and
and then he tells me to cut it out
yeah it was it was david yeah so you're
doing play-by-play watching the game
with dave and dave doesn't want to hear
you do
exactly well actually you know that's
the way i started and my brothers alan
steen who also did nba games
we would turn down the sound of the tv
and do games on our tape recorder and my
son kenny did the same
with basketball and hockey and we had
our own
fictitious radio station uh
and uh it was great practice at the time
little did i know that i'd be doing
virtual
calls these days off the television set
you know so i was good good practice for
what's taking place now with both uh
tnt and espn great to talk to you have
fun during the post season
and uh please my give my best to heather
and uh thank you
thanks for joining us mark anytime dan
thank you i enjoy
listening and watching to watching you
all the time so
thanks so much that's uh marv albert
going to retire at the end of the
postseason